[Musique]
quand même une vraie une vraie confusion
sur les décisions l'equilibre d'ailleurs
on le sent bien vous les uns les eaux
dans les différents organes de presse
c'est ça ressort des tensions entre
l'elysée et matignon et entre matignon
et les ministres là par exemple sur le
déconfinement premier ministre avait
prévu de l'annoncé dans huit jours
mais il est doublé par certains de ses
ministres qui se précipitent pour
annoncer les mesures
vous savez moi je pense que cette crise
là c'est l'occasion de gérer l'urgence
mais c'est aussi l'occasion de se
reposer les questions absolument
fondamental sur notre modèle pardon
meuwly révolutionnaire mais tout ce que
je peux aujourd'hui assure yves séguin
pays une grande nation qui est pas
capable d'assurer dans une période
d'urgence et de crise alimentation de
l'ensemble de ses concitoyens
c'est un pays qui est en échec il est
pour moi important de reprendre une
activité rapidement notamment dans le
grand ouest où on voit bien que
l'ensemble des régions et notamment la
région pays de la loire est moins
touchée alors bien évidemment reprendre
plus rapidement mais avec des des
mesures sanitaires très strictes s'agit
pas de sacrifier la santé des français
sur le thème de l'économie il s'agit de
mener les deux choses de façon conjointe
et c'est bien le sens des propositions
qui encore une fois ne sont pas des
contre propositions mais nous avons
réfléchi à cette question du
déconfinement parce qu'elle est
extrêmement importante parce que nous
voyons bien que le gouvernement a été
empêtré dans des propositions
contradictoires c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons travaillé très
sérieusement dans un esprit de
responsabilité comme une faisons depuis
le début de la crise l'urgence
aujourd'hui objectivement c'est les
masques les tests et de encore une fois
de réarmer notre note rhodia talent
d'état manqué de prévision et de
préparation et ce avec sur le terrain ou
une situation qui est absolument
incroyable
il faudra demain relocaliser nos
industries notamment l'industrie
pharmaceutique est ce qu'on peut laisser
je l'avais écrit à quelques mois est-ce
qu'on peut laisser la chine être la
pharmacie et le monde et de l'europe
pour faut de la cohérence
il faut de la responsabilité il faut
surtout de la clarté aujourd'hui c'est
les incertitudes qui font que et bien il
ya un flou généralisée
et on créer de l'anxiété on crée de
langoat là au contraire le rôle du
gouvernement c'est de rassurer les
français une gestion absolument
cacophonie qui a trop de contradictions
demande au gouvernement ou à la clark
point fondamental c'est de sortir de
cette vision aberrante qui consiste à
vouloir tout transformer tout le temps
tout changer tout le temps et de revenir
à une politique plus humbles qui se
donne pour point cardinal pour vertu
cardinale ce qu'aristote appelé la
prudence la grande vertu politique c'est
à dire la capacité de protéger ceux pour
qui vous vous engagez est de faire en
sorte que nous puissions demain absorber
les crises qui se présenteront parce
qu'il y aura d'autres crises et je crois
que on parlait tout à l'heure
d'alimentation on devrait parler de
sécurité
on devrait parler de numérique on
devrait parler évidemment de santé sur
tous ces sujets là il faut que nous
soyons capables d'être résilient pour
absorber les chocs de demain et
conserver cette souveraineté qui fait
notre liberté
[Musique]